Annie could potentially be pregnant
first of all the big question is do you
two want a baby is that something you
want
your first your first it is something
that we have talked about and you know
I've always left it to her discretion
that if it's something that she wants
that I am 100 on board with the last
period like for three months I didn't
have my period
I didn't think I would ever think about
being a father again
ah this is a womb can you see holy cow
what I am doing
David and Annie first of all Annie happy
belated birthday thank you so much big
30 big 3-0 if you're surprising to a lot
of people that you're only 30. you're
talking for your age one
um
24 so he always wished one day you can
be turkey one day you're gonna be 30. he
just feel like you do if you wish it
just come through that's because I'm not
aging I'm just holding waiting for to
catch up how do you feel how does it
feel to be the big 3-0 I turned 30 next
year so cool I mean uh I feel really
good I feel really good about myself I'm
happy with my life you know even know
that certain things go like what I want
but you know what 30 is great celebrate
another year of Life another year of
living because a lot of people they have
that opportunity to celebrate day 30.
very true Amen to that well congrats on
season two of David and Annie after the
90 days thank you so much thank you I'm
curious what are you most excited for
people to see this time around I really
feel I think some of the most exciting
things is we are going back to Thailand
seeing the culture seeing the different
aspects of Thailand the food the culture
the family the people you know being
able to share that with not just
Americans but people around the world I
think that's what bridge that's what
closes divines is sharing culture and
food to me I'm really really excited for
the new season because I just feel like
I mean it is a real another game of
American TV show because it's not that
the show is a real you know especially
with the culture with a lot of things
going on there I'm sure anyone have any
of American TV show have this scene what
we are going to show you oh I'm excited
that was a really good thing okay well
something we saw in the trailer that
stopped everyone in their tracks
Annie could potentially be pregnant the
big question is do you two want a baby
is that something you want
it is something that we have talked
about and whatever will be will be and
just stay tuned and you know I've always
left it to her discretion that if it's
something that she wants that I am 100
on board and um
stay tuned to me you know we talked on
and off about that
I just feel like oh I'm young I'm still
gonna have more time and now from the
activity I have to make my last decision
you know like do I want it or not
because not just me getting ordered my
husband is already grandfather so if I
wait for a couple years he will be a
great great grandfather so I don't want
great great great friend Father just
have a newborn I mean it's goodness so
uh kind of a normal not normal I just
worry about David because when you say
he asked me once so but I just feel like
sometimes he just want me to happy to
hear that tell me what I want to hear he
not tell me what exactly you want yeah
because last time I checked David you
had a vasectomy so yes
I know you said that if any one of you
to reverse it you would
yeah
I don't know Annie has so much love and
patience and I think Annie will be a
great mother
yeah except for a house plant that we're
not good with
fake plants we we killed our basil plant
but that's because we travel so much we
are taking Amber and Jordan down to
Phuket Thailand so we can enroll the
kids in an English language school when
they go to the NBC next time boom get
the visa well let's get into this trip
to Thailand you're going Annie's brother
Jordan and your cousin Amber to try to
get them their visas to go to school in
America but it seems as if Jordan is
still resisting Coming to America so
what can you tease about the situation
you're gonna find yourself in with him
you know I think like most teenagers
it's always ambiguous about what they
want they wake up one morning want this
and by the afternoon they want something
different so I think we're going to see
a lot of Transformations uh along the
way
and that should you know my oldest
granddaughter is 16. and who's six
months older than Jordan so you know you
see that no matter whether it's an
American or it's high teenager they're
Ever Changing you know we always change
our mind you know even what we want for
dinner
the best for him I do love him very much
but sometimes you know I cannot
understand what's going on in his mind
but he Shades every hour so it's very
very hard to produce that I think so
many people can relate to that because
there are many cases where someone like
you gets out of an environment and they
go back to try to help their loved ones
you know
create a better life as well so how do
you deal with that emotionally and
mentally because I'm sure it's tough oh
my God it's really really tough you know
what how can a deal is I mean I have to
take a dirty face for us
have to count you know and just say like
I have to be more patient and patient on
him and patient and you know what
sometimes I just uh broke my patient
whether it's her brother or anybody else
when they haven't left their environment
they don't know what opportunities are
out there in the world that present
themselves
and bringing Amber and Jordan to America
is very important because it is the way
to break the cycle of poverty and they
come from an area of Thailand that
doesn't have the opportunities that you
would have in the bigger cities or in
places like America or even Europe or uh
and it's important not even just for
them but for other people to see there's
a big world out there for sure I was
curious about that because I know that
some people they feel guilt they feel
shame you know there's so much that
comes with being the one that makes it
out of your family and then feeling that
responsibility you know to bring others
along
it's not even so much an obligation as
it is out of wealth you're bringing my
daughter and granddaughter Ashley and
Aubrey to Thailand is to show them and
give a better understanding of what life
is like over there where Annie came from
and why this is so important
Society is quality of us the first
season the first time when you choose
the mean she always said oh that which
come from she's trying to reaching you
she tried to uh fight with sugar daddy
she's about the green card that's where
she from she's from Thailand so she has
no clue what the Thailand is about so
it's gonna be good you know for her to
see some signs of Thailand that's
Thailand she never been before she not
even heard or know about that before so
I think it's gonna be very very
interesting and very challenged yeah I
know so many of us are just happy to see
you and Ashley reconnecting David and
then Annie your relationship with Ashley
blasphemy because as you mentioned it
wasn't always great so how would you
describe where you stand now even after
the trip to Thailand
oh I think a relationship gets stronger
every day
um no relationship is perfect with any
family but you know we're growing and
it's evolving and every one of us is
getting older you know we lost my dad
two years ago December of 2020 and I
think that put a lot of things in
perspective of how short like it is yeah
what about you Annie how was it for you
to see Ashley there learning about your
culture and spending time with your
family
it is so awesome to see as we be able to
travel you know with us to Thailand and
uh to show her my culture My Lifestyle
how I growing up how my family over
there you know to introduce her to a new
food to the new stuff over there she's
not even heard or know about before and
then hopefully we can do more together
in the future you know to be in her
relationship and mine you know who is
Billy court is but you know I'm her
stepmom I just look at her like as a
friend so it's nothing against that but
you know in every relationship we still
have some issue inside for sure for sure
we'll progress is what counts yes so
moving forward not backwards well after
five years of marriage you two you seem
stronger than ever and I'm sure you get
this question all the time but
today what is your take on the secret to
your success in your relationship as a
couple if you could answer just how you
feel today right now
I feel like our relationship is stronger
and stronger each and every day and part
of it is and I've said this before is
every day is like the movie 50 First
Dates I have to make her fall in love
with me all over again each and every
day
and we have not been apart longer than
12 hours we do everything together
yeah yes uh to me for five years I mean
we just learned about it a lot we accept
the part that's perfect of each other we
learn from that we've grown from that
and we just enjoying life together as
much as we can you know and just cheer
each other up you know when and awake it
always got AJ too bad and like the stuff
that you would normally people would
argue over we just laugh at yeah we
found the humor in everything like we
balance it is like when I got hot here
TVB award who will try to you know pull
me make it cool and when he tried to get
the heart hit I just yeah you know try
to make me food out just for lunch in
the relationship is not just about you
know the uh how how much can you do for
asiator is how much can you help AJ to
live up hey man I love that we just we
do not argue we really don't have we
never say words that we have to say
sorry for
is due to the love you have for each
other and just where you are personally
in your lives
the part of that is the way of our
personality in life because we want
something very similar we want something
to say I'm like I don't like argue we
don't like argue we like to make it work
we make it work we we just kind of like
a sample so just like different body
differently
is the American man why it can be big
nose so my breasts are bigger
so it's just just you know pretty much
same mindset you know pretty much very
pretty much and of course you know you
have to have love in the relationship
between husband and wife just don't
forget that you know but the most
important thing after your bedroom is
how you live your life together
yeah and we truly believe if two people
stick together
and you don't let anybody come between
you nobody gets between us yeah
sometimes
well I will say February you bring you
you as a couple you two together bring
so much joy to the 90-day Universe you
know thank you so much we're honored to
be a part of you know what is not just
pop culture but it really is America it
is people from all because America is
people from all over the world
and to be a part of it we consider one
big family whether it is the producers
the network the fans other cast members
it's one family that is part of history
now going on to its 10th season I guess
for the 90-day original yeah and to just
be a part of it it feels like one big
family yeah even the ones that hate me
[Laughter]
exactly
for the hate
[Music]